joe biden is very strongly suggesting to  americans a great way to save on gas is  get yourself an electric vehicle now i  agree with joe biden a thousand percent  i have an electric vehicle it's  fantastic the electricity is cheaper  than the gas  you are even if the electricity comes  from fossil fuels you're centralizing  the burning of those fossil fuels and  the cars driving around don't emit it  also is more efficient than gas vehicles  the problem is number one electric  vehicles are expensive number two we  don't have nearly enough chargers and so  for the average person we need way more  subsidies and incentives on electric  vehicles and we need way more chargers  as well the second piece joe biden is  working on money for chargers in the  infrastructure bill the first part we've  got to up significantly those electric  vehicle tax credits